hey what's up beautiful people welcome
to another episode of get close I'm Geo
um Bart and this is my Andrew Tate uh
appearance
uh why I'm just kidding because he
always wears sunglasses in his
interviews but he's indoors but I
actually need it because the sun is
coming through and [ __ ] blasting in
my eyes because we don't have her
[ __ ] drapes in you I don't remember
we
oh before we get to anything
if you guys have been listening to this
podcast
and you guys like it please like and
share turn on notifications so you're
always notified when we have new uploads
whether the podcasts or Vlogs I feel
like we're really bad YouTubers we were
never hitting the algorithm to do
anything to help grow the channel and
it's just been growing based off of our
Die Hard fans but we should help grow it
together so if you like our stuff hit
the like button share it and don't
forget to turn on notifications big CUNY
I love it yeah we're horrible at doing
that [ __ ] I just realized as you were
talking you have a crazy underbite
yeah
oh do your teeth go behind or in front
of like as you're talking it looks like
you're
like your teeth go behind the bottom row
I think I have a slight underbite yeah
[ __ ] I made a kid with someone that has
a [ __ ] under bite taco doesn't have
an underbite I mean he's headed in that
direction with your [ __ ] up Grill what
do you mean headed in that direction his
he used to have smile cute it was like
that he had an underbite see that's cool
that's why you made a kid with me
because then you have cute kids you
[ __ ] dumbass you know what I don't
appreciate the way you're talking to me
that's how Andrew Tate talks to women so
I'm like maybe I should learn something
anyway so today I want to talk about
something because
um I was thinking about this in the car
I was thinking about the woman that I am
today yeah and I was thinking about how
proud I am of myself yes yeah you're not
proud of yourself no I'm saying you're
proud of yourself I am proud of myself
of like where I started to where I'm at
now I'm gonna think about that a little
bit more I'm really proud of myself no I
don't I'm actually pretty confident
that's Kenny um so it got me to think
like
do you feel
like you've became
like the person you wanted to be like
your ideal like person you look up to
like do you feel like you're close to
that you became that or you're far from
that
I think I'm pretty close but I also
think I got
um some extra toppings that I didn't
think I would have
excuse me
are you hungry you're excused are you
hungry no okay what the [ __ ] are what
are these toppings what are you talking
about so um when I was a kid the people
that I really really looked up to were
like generals and stuff
what kid what do we think about five
shut the [ __ ] up you knew about generals
how do you know about generals are your
parents showing you [ __ ] War [ __ ]
videos those are the only ones I get to
watch shut up yeah my mom would show me
like so there's like a very
um
uh really famous like storyline in
Chinese
um I guess folklore story but it's also
history where it's uh it's like the
Three Kingdoms the battle of the Three
Kingdoms yeah so the dynasties yeah yeah
so you know how um there's like a a very
famous like Chinese Warlord he has like
the red face do I know that no
absolutely you know of it because we
have statues of him at my dad's house
that we all I don't really pay attention
everywhere we go I point them out to you
thank you for listening anyways
um
is that the one that shares your last
name yes that's why so like anybody
that's a quan it's like the Chinese God
of War his last name is actually Quan so
anyone that is a quan is so proud he's
got the red face he's always holding the
building like a big why does he have a
red face was he drunk no
oh because he's pissed he's fiery it has
something to do with like one of those
mythical things like I think he washed
his face and then the gods wanted to
show something I forgot what it was but
anyways I'm happy you've been listening
too yeah I haven't been listening
because my mom's telling talking to me
so be quiet
um
because of that I've always been very
interested in like
Warlords generals like Warriors what
about that nachos what do you like about
them
just honor I just really like honorable
people and then people that
um make the right decisions and hard
times
I've always just liked that so all the
movies where you see like sacrifice or
like like when I first found out that
samurais killed themselves I'm like that
is badass you know when they go I [ __ ]
up and they go
and then they got the homie that was
like I wish people would still do that
today I wish they would too not like
actually killing themselves but take it
to that extreme where they're like I
[ __ ] up or even got ashamed of myself
even like there's no accountability you
know they cut off their fingers when
they [ __ ] up no you don't know about
that no
so if you go to Japan and if you ever
see a guy like some poking tattoos
popping out they're probably Yakuza if
they're whole like they got the body
suit on and then they probably have some
chopped up what the [ __ ] is a body suit
like I know a bodysuit as in Spanish
fashion body suit but what's a body are
you a [ __ ] Boomer with a bodysuit
like if you are fully blasted from like
neck to toe oh tattoos yeah I was
thinking no no I got it I was thinking
because you said it's Peak I'm not
talking about [ __ ] leotards no I
thought you because you were like it's
peeking out so I thought now you're
talking about the attire and what that's
called I'm like what's a bodysuit like a
bodysuit I get it batteries legs I get
that now but you just said it was poking
out of there like it's poking out of
their apparel yeah it is when you have a
body suit and you have to have and then
connected to your neck piece I get it
bro move it on all right and then you
see like Yakuza guys with like missing
fingers is because anytime you get
[ __ ] up or you [ __ ] up and you like
dishonor or you mess up like a deal
whatever they'll chop off a segment of
your knuckle oh they chop it off for you
yeah that's not as honorable as [ __ ]
sabuku what is that called yeah but it's
still badass
because like that's how hardcore they
are so I've always liked that I always
liked [ __ ] like people are just
[ __ ] hardcore down for their [ __ ]
like no [ __ ] allowed type [ __ ] you
know yeah yeah and so ever since I was a
kid I always wanted to be someone like
that I always wanted to be like I want
to be like a warrior someone that like
has moral stands by something you know
and not [ __ ] shifting with the times
all the time yeah yeah and then so the
top the extra Toppings is I didn't know
I was gonna be a goofball too and I
didn't know I was going to be such a
silly man
um okay so you feel like you're close to
that to being super honorable
um
I feel like I definitely stand by my
virtues and my morals and uh I think
I've always wanted to be like the
stand-up strong dad
that like
um a son would want to Aspire to be
because I never aspired to be my dad
you know so I was like man I wish that I
wished I had a dad that because people
were like oh my dad's my superhero or
whatever I just want to be like my dad
you know like there's so many people you
hear when they like in interviews
they're like man I'm only half the
person my dad was or whatever you know I
mean like
um I wish I had that I didn't have that
how did you see your dad as someone
that's what
um
I I'm too young to uh to to like really
know
but I just know that when my parents got
divorced that's not right I see you know
regardless of whose fault it was right
right I just go like
that's not right
and um
that's not what you want yeah I think
because you saw the trail of like
Brokenness it left everywhere yeah yeah
oh [ __ ] so it just didn't feel like
someone handled their [ __ ] you know yeah
because to me I'm like dudes are like at
six you were feeling that yeah because I
mean all the content I watched like all
the movies and stories that I would read
about it was
um about like what a man what a man
meant to me was like someone that
handled their [ __ ] at six Tech is five
I can't
imagine him comprehending it that deep
you don't know let's ask him
you ask them like what does a man mean
to you
he might he might be he might have a way
deeper thought than you think
yeah maybe I'm like cutting him down
because he might be like a man is blade
okay I will ask him I'll take a note of
that ask taika about what a man yeah
because it meant like that's I would
just watch these war movies and stuff
and I'm like oh that's a man you know
like when you see like even in like a uh
timepieces right you got the dude that
comes in like command's presence and he
got the court gesture yes sir what
happened David so right like yeah you
have a bar and then you have a David so
I think I'm look gorgeous too but when
you see it like in your as a with boy
eyes you're like oh they're both
grown-ups and they're both men but I
think that one's manly yeah you just
have this gut feeling you know or like
even like you watch Lion King and then
Mufasa comes
and you have the hyenas you're like
that's a man yeah you're like it's like
I want to be like Mufasa
it's a warrior you know I don't be like
scarred no no no no no no like scars and
slimy yeah so even as a kid like you
just you notice these things and I just
wanted to be like I want to be a Mufasa
too
yeah that's CUNY okay so and now to
answer your question I feel like I am
the Mufasa too taka Simba that's CUNY
um what I want to know now is how are
you so confident that you're close to
like what in your history
what decisions have you made or what
actions have you taken that you're like
ah this is this is the right way this is
what I wanted to represent like this is
when I was a kid and I was five and I
was looking at those like I I'm faced
with that decision and I think I made
the right one like what is that
specifically
um
there's actually a couple of categories
that are really important to me
so one is doing the doing
hard things
and making
the right decisions and hard times
so like if uh
when me and Tyco like if we need to get
something out of the car like it's
really small but I think it builds like
everything gets scaled you know like
like let's say we have to get something
out of the car and it's cold
and then he's like oh it's cold and I
want to go outside you know like no we
have to we have to go do it and then I'm
like we could put on a jacket and put on
Jack and be brave or even like when we
helped him like Get over his whole wind
phobia remember he still has it yeah
like this crazy windfall being like oh
well we could do one step but we'll hold
each other's hand but we'll go one step
in front of the other you know and
really try to help build this confidence
and I feel like a big part of being like
a man in my eyes are like someone that I
looked up to is someone that can like
like in the Marine Corps it's very
simple it's like you got to carry your
own weight but sometimes you can't it's
[ __ ] heavy and you you the stud
muffins always come like yo give me give
me a rifle give me whatever let's go
come on let's go and they'll push you
from the back you're like [ __ ] I feel
uplifted you know and then once you
start getting back give me my rifle but
I got this now I got this so I feel like
you land you're like that Pillar of
Strength so I feel like I'm definitely
the Pillar of Strength with taika and uh
the other thing is um helping him
achieve what he wants because I think
that's one thing that was missing
probably generationally is always the
parents wanting to do what they want
and me like going like what do you want
to do like I want to like climb that
thing and then take my bike to that
thing I'm like oh yeah
that would be a tiger moment take my
bike to that thing yeah okay we'll
figure it out we'll do it together you
know and really try to help them and do
it together and then also help like if
there's any lessons along the way help
not like uh spoon feed into him but help
reveal the lessons to himself so then
for you it sounds like you've just
recently discovered this like you've as
soon as you came became a father I think
I mean from what I'm listen or hearing
is that you just recently discovered
that you're becoming the man you wanted
to be yeah because I think becoming a
father is the ultimate test how so
um
you know they say like you're not a
master until you can teach
it's like that I think it's like the
difference between like in BJJ like
brown belt and a black belt you know
like but how do you know you're teaching
the right thing you don't know to be
honest so then how do you know you just
measured it you just go based off your
feel and how I feel and how taika views
me yeah so then that leads me to believe
though that you've been building this
this up like you've had decisions in
your life the hard decision that you've
had to make that you're proud of
right if you get me like the little baby
Stepping Stones leading up to um
who I thought yeah yeah so those are the
ones I want to uncover so you know
watching those movies and also one thing
that my mom always like harped on was
when will schwang Trin which means
exactly exactly yeah yeah konichiwa
[ __ ]
um which is also like his favorite thing
right yeah which is um
when means like
like a scholarly
and then means Marshall like Marsh like
uh like martial arts or like Combat
Warrior yeah like that so Swang Trin
means both complete so my mom said
something my mom always taught me which
is you need to be intellectual and you
also need to be Warrior and you have to
be both complete so in my mind I think
that's why like when I was trying to go
to UCLA and be a marine it was a dual
goal it I needed to do both together
like that's why like I chose the path
that I did so I can do that so like that
was like the stepping stone to getting
to
the uh
the warrior man that I wanted to be and
even in my own weird way of like
sidewinding even like joining gangs was
like a warrior yeah because I probably
like felt like such a little [ __ ] as a
kid yeah you know was my mom [ __ ]
dressing me [ __ ] and then I'm like man I
need to express my [ __ ] like Teenage
masculinity somehow oh those guys look
kind of fun like tough you know
everybody to do tough [ __ ]
and then so like I grew up in a place
where there's gangs but if there was
like a bunch of dudes that like
skateboarded or just a bunch of other
dudes that did like more like stuff
that's gonna get you hurt a little bit
there's like a little bit of risk but
you gotta like a little bit of
commitment I would have done any of
those things
um and I felt like I had to get that out
of my system so like little
little like tough hard things that you
kind of have to earn your badge to be in
the group I wanted to get into those
those circles because that to me is kind
of like uh
a rite of passage you know like when you
don't have to audition for something and
you're it you didn't really earn it
right but like if you earned your place
to be in the gang that's like one step
if you earned your place to get into a
good school that's another step so you
earn your constanting or you're
constantly earning your next spot you
know yeah yeah
that's so cool that you had that um that
you had that already instilled in you
like it could have gone completely
different so it was cool that your mom
was presenting that to you as an option
right yeah you didn't even know that it
was even an option luckily for you it
just so happened to click because
someone that's a little bit more timid
and to themselves and reserved and isn't
about that and wants to be more of an
artist or it's just more you know what I
mean like if that was presented to them
it could have it just could have gone
over their head or just would have
turned them off completely and then it
would have just been bad or just it just
it wouldn't have clicked
um so it's really cool that you're
already that way just straight out of
the womb and then your mom's also
enforcing that and that's really tight
and it's really really helpful
um but like
yeah like I mean there's no specific
time where you're like man that was
[ __ ] hard and like I didn't want to
do that but I did do it you know because
that's just what a man does I feel like
you do it literally every day
I feel like you're always faced with
these things and I've seen it come from
you time and time and time again that's
what I'm surprised that maybe you're
just so used to it that you're just like
I don't know I just breathe and that's
it well you think I'm manly every day I
think you make a lot of um tough
decisions really yeah I mean that's what
that's what why I'm so attracted to you
because you're so
oh God what up guys this episode is
brought to you by the one and only
manscapes and what I have in my hand is
the lawnmower
4.0 which I use religiously every week
to keep myself nice and trimmed and
presentable and ready to make taika's
brother or sister you know what I'm
saying and that's what I love about
manscape because they have a whole
plethora of options to keep the dude
let's face it dudes are kind of nasty
more appealing to ourselves and our
significant others and if you guys are
looking for gift ideas this is perfect
because they have a ton of stocking
stuffers so for example like the
Platinum package 4.0 comes loads of
little presents perfect for stocking
stuffers like a handful of their liquid
formulations shampoos body washes
upstairs and downstairs deodorants gels
exfoliants there's shears 2.0 is their
full kit for Nail Care which I also use
has scissors Clippers tweezers if you're
ever traveling and and you need to keep
your grooming under control boom nice
easy package throw in your backpack and
you're ready to go you don't have to
worry about throwing out your crazy nose
hairs or you have like cat like
fingernails or anything like that also
they have the persevere cologne which is
a light Breezy woodsy feel gives that
fresh tree scent even after the holidays
are over because you always want to
smell fresh and they also have a body
buffer which you can use to scrub your
skin and right now if you use the code
get close you get 20 off at checkout
plus free shipping and we all know with
the increase of gas prices how much
shipping can be so make sure you use
that code get close to get 20 percent
off plus free shipping to buy yourself a
gift or a gift for someone else
manscaped because you're just um you're
able to make tough decisions really
quickly you're able to put yourself last
your family first even when it was us
together like
um you're always down to take the harder
out you know like you're just like all
right well this is I mean just you do
have a warrior mindset another phrase my
mom used to tell me was uh and I was
about to get this tatted on me actually
it's
it's really deep it means um marry the
Mexican girl in your life will be
awesome no no it's uh it means um
the harder of the struggles that you go
through or that you put yourself through
the higher Echelon of a person you
become
damn she was telling you that yeah so
ever ever so you understand the [ __ ]
gold yes it was suffocating yes it was
hard but like
you grew up with a lot of [ __ ] gold
yeah so like maybe I maybe I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] for not succeed even more but um
yeah like my mom like when I would like
do kung fu whatever it would get tough
my mom would tell me that you know and
that actually got me through boot camp
like a lot of like tough times I'm like
oh yeah the harder [ __ ] you become the
the the higher person you like Elevate
yourself to be so you got to go through
hardship go through hardship that's so
cool I wish I had [ __ ] like that
anything that I've ever um what do you
have let's not cry later
I guess that really didn't stick with me
but like any uh uh what is that called
um Proverbs not Proverbs but like any
conclusion or any problems that I've
solved or any like a homo me uh yeah
epiphanies
um I've just come up with them on my own
or I've heard it from like an outside
Source recently you know but like it
wasn't anything that was like ever
like told to me so that's so sick like I
I'm like what would I have achieved if I
would have I mean who knows right like
maybe I was too immature that is one
thing that I'm very appreciative of the
Asian culture yeah the bars are built in
it's [ __ ] time there's [ __ ] bars
for everything so I think and by bars
you mean like philosophical lessons yeah
okay so like um those bars are built in
so that you don't have to reinvent the
wheel
and you can immediately start building
the minute your mind accepts one of them
yeah
That's So Dope like you know like stuff
that's like um like early bird catches
the worm right it's like the minute you
accept that
you're like I'm gonna get up early then
you know because yeah because if I get
up early the other birds are still
sleeping so I get to see the worms
before the other birds do and everyone's
getting scraps some get up early
so like a lot of those bars are built in
um and if you can accept it because it's
that's that's the toughest part actually
and uh and start acting on it it helps
build like the whole Community yeah for
sure if you had to rate okay so think
back when you were like five six and you
had your ideal of what a man is and what
you know what you looked up to
that five six year old now looks at this
bar this current
Bart what what grading what grade does
he give Bart a being you nailed it he
might be confused because people like
this guy is kind of dope but he's also
[ __ ] silly I didn't think I was gonna
be silly uh yeah I thought because you
know every warrior ever met they're not
funny or not that I ever met but like
ever read about or watched they're like
serious dudes they're like you know just
Warrior like a [ __ ] Mel Gibson or
some [ __ ] you know and then like a Tom
Hardy like you don't really see like
like a Kevin Hart
like any quirks about them and so um
I think I'd be confused
and uh not know how to correctly rate
them maybe like a and F at the same time
or something
oh [ __ ] okay well now you Curry and you
looking back at what BART I mean little
Bart wanted
uh putting aside the goofy goofy time
because that's probably a crazy defense
mechanism that you've developed over the
years yeah
um putting that off to the side do you
think you've achieved it
or great or grade that
I would probably give it like a B plus I
think B plus where's the plus come from
like what what puts you over the edge
I think
um if I
took my military and
educational career a little bit further
I think you would get an A okay what but
that's basing it from the lens of
of when I was a kid you know so when I
was a kid I need to be more intellectual
and more warrior-like so if I became
like special ops and I got a masters
then that's like both but this is so
dope but as I got older I was like
becoming realizing what a passion was
you know and so with with the if I were
to grade myself now I think I'd give
myself a but with my baby eyes I think
I'll give it like a B plus okay for your
baby eyes what would you have had to
achieve in the military like Special
Operations of some sort oh so like the
highest pedigree of it yeah because when
I joined the military I didn't even know
that like SEALS or all the other ones
existed I just listened I just saw the
phrase Marine Corps the few and the
proud I'm like that's bad I'm a liar and
you saw the fire and you saw the
commercials where they're like [ __ ]
coming out of the mud and they're like
eyes are just like this and they have
paint on their face yeah and I was like
that's badass yeah but then what they
don't tell you is the guys that get to
do that are the special special
operations and I was like I didn't know
that I was cleaning trash cans the first
year got it okay so that's what baby
Bart would have wanted to see what about
in your academic career being a doctor
probably a doctor some sort of a
doctorate degree some sort of master's
degree of some sort so not even a doctor
you wouldn't even want to be at the
highest degree just
Master yeah just because like I think
just above the standard because when I
was a kid if special ops isn't above the
standard well you got to be more worrier
yeah Warriors got to come past the
intellectual why oh because that's the
definition of a man for you yeah from my
from my definition of a role model of
hands not soft hands yeah I don't want
to be uh I don't want to have like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] PhD dad
you know I don't want to [ __ ] like I
don't wanna the last thing I wanted was
you know like Honey I Shrunk the Kids
yeah have a dad like that we're [ __ ]
like he's smart as [ __ ] and then
something happened he's [ __ ] pissing
his pants yeah yeah I didn't want that
either yeah so I would be like some sort
of Masters or something okay so then
right now you said you looking at
yourself now you give yourself an a yeah
why
because I think those are very uh
external
achievements external like you know um
yeah
and
um I think something that
might even take a little bit more
courage is actually going against
everything you ever thought was to
pursue you passion and that takes a lot
of Courage you know to because those two
are set paths or you're really stupid
like those are set paths right like you
get good grades you apply like yeah it's
comfy yeah you take take your GRE or MBA
or whatever you need to take GMAT else
at whatever and you bam same thing here
you you go into regular military then
you go to selection and if you pass and
you go to the actual uh course for the
special ops and you get in it's a very
like you know what you have to do it's
if you can do it or not
to pursue your passion if especially if
it's a career that has never been
invented before you're literally
dropping everything you know to go
I'm gonna figure it out you know it's
almost like trying to invent a cure
for something that you don't even really
know yeah and then so for that I'm like
I was actually like either really stupid
like you said or man that's that was
pretty brave and that's pretty cool and
that's innovative
so that I would give myself an a there
because
um because I've done that I have the
confidence and I have the floor to stand
on to share that with taika so if he
ever wants to do something yeah had I
not done that I'm like no that path
doesn't exist like you would you know
but now you should be scared yeah now
I'm like let's go baby like you you
think you want to build a fast food
restaurant on the moon like I can I
could maybe see that happening let's
let's see let's let's brainstorm you
know yeah super CUNY yeah what about you
really tight what about me are you proud
of your bro who you are and if are you a
role model to the little Geo that you
were man you gave such an eloquent
um answer and it felt like you've been
dying to [ __ ] share this because like
I know I'm just saying that cars are
built in that's how well presented this
was you know it felt like it was
something that was already reserved in
your brain yeah where for me I I maybe I
just don't know how to like elaborate
um but I'm definitely proud of myself
um like as when you were a little girl
who were like
the head highness that you're like oh
man she's cool she's cool I'm gonna be
like her I don't think I had that I
think I had the ones of like I don't
want that I don't want to be like you I
don't want that I don't want that so I
had that more than the role models so
the same way you pick what you want to
eat is the same way you took role models
I don't know what I want I just know
what I don't lie well I knew I was I was
different like I've always felt
different yeah
um like the women around me I
appreciated every and I think this is
why I started developing this I never
felt that in my immediate vicinity was
anyone that I'm like that's that's what
I want to be what about movies or like
music well I knew that was fake I knew
that was fake but you could still have a
um like when we asked Joe who his role
model was as a kid yeah guess what he
said what Mickey Mouse
to Leonardo Leonardo the turtle the
turtle and we're like no that's actually
pretty tight no dude he's a complicated
character I was like you know I was like
you got any like regular people [ __ ]
like oh man like Tony Hawk's really cool
I like skateboarding and he goes
nah
I knew he was gonna pick some fictional
character you didn't even have a
fictional character that I looked up to
no not really like even as a kid like
when you got it when you got into Greek
mythology people like all of the
Hercules I want to be Zeus yeah they
throw lightning bolts no no I don't
think I had that I think I had more of
the like okay so I knew that TV and
everything that lived in there is
fictional and it's fake but they're
still representing something absolutely
but I'm just saying back then with my
mindset that's why I didn't go towards
that because it wasn't real for me so
yes it had characteristics of things
that I liked for sure
um but the only thing I could really
base it off of was real life and the
people around me and what I was exposed
to so because of that and because I
didn't have the role model and I didn't
have you know the people that I really
looked up to I just had the examples I
didn't want to become
um I I started developing this thing
where if I would meet people because
they weren't what I wanted to be they
would have characteristics or traits
that I wanted to possess myself
so then I I would really gravitate
towards that and then really try to
understand it and dissect it and really
try hard to make that trait my own trait
you never gotten into like biographies
no
oh I didn't like to read oh that was a
huge thing too because I remember
reading about Joan of Arc yeah I'm like
damn a 13 year old girl LED Army maybe I
was too stupid maybe I didn't like
really comprehend I had ass or like
Amelia Earhart
let me learn more about her yeah I
thought that was cool and then I as I
got older like in high school I started
really looking into
um that's when I would start looking at
like
um different artists like
um like
um like Amelia Earhart she's not an
artist but like I would look at
different people like that no but I
would I would start looking at stuff
like that but growing up I didn't have
that so my first first role model if I
had to pick one was probably my sister
she was she was my first one because she
was what I was exposed to and she
represented to me when I was really
young she represented she was really
mouthy so she was like
um yeah she felt really tough to me
um too anyone and everyone so she's
gonna take no [ __ ] yeah she wouldn't
take [ __ ] from anyone from what I
perceived it yeah right
um so she was my first role model and
like I would see her in her relationship
and it just felt like again I didn't
know what a healthy relationship was
looking back at it now I'm like
toxic as [ __ ] but as a kid it just felt
like oh they're very secure and they're
comfortable with each other and like
um like it just felt really innocent and
stuff and I really liked all that so she
was my first role model and then as soon
as I started getting older and like
realizing and having my own thoughts I
was like oh [ __ ] that's not at all what
I perceived it to be I think I was
putting on my own like version of a
warrior on my sister and like really
going like oh this is a set path but I
think once I started getting exposed to
more people and seeing how other people
live and solve problems and handle
themselves I'm like oh [ __ ] that's not
what it was at all yeah
um so so looking back at what I wanted
and what I needed as a as a kid that I
didn't have looking at myself now and
going [ __ ] like if I had myself as a
little as a big sister
they'd be so [ __ ] tight like I would
[ __ ] love it what do you like about
yourself now that you think your little
self would have really liked
um someone that is very encouraging you
know someone that's Brave with their
decisions someone that is down to be
like oh that's what you want to try yeah
let's just check it out because I was
always confronted with so much
um like fear everything was always like
fear driven you know the fear of not
enough money or the fear of
um being judged or the fear of not being
smart enough or the fear of uh like all
of that like every everything that I was
every decision that was made was always
based on fear I felt like and I'm like
what the [ __ ] do you have to fear about
you know like why is there so much fear
in every decision like you don't want to
go to this place because they're gonna
judge you and I'm like who gives a [ __ ]
or you don't want to answer this
question because you know you're gonna
sound stupid you know you're not smart
enough or you don't have you know the
right money you know like I'm just like
what the [ __ ] this is [ __ ] crazy to
me that's why I loved biographies
because it [ __ ] shut my parents the
[ __ ] cup like I would hear all these
things oh no you don't do that like I
got first let go like oh you know what
like I feel like Comfort I don't think
we're really sparring because like as
soon as we land a strike like
um we would stop it I don't know if
that's real fighting I'm like you know
when you're boxing like the round keeps
going doesn't matter how many punches
you got to see how it does no no you get
hurt and all that yeah and then so I
would read like like even um I was
really into skateboarding so I'd read
trans World magazine and they'll talk
about like the skater you started like
you know skating when it was 12 whatever
and now he's like 19 he's signed and
then you're just reading like how he
broke 17 bones and you're just like oh
that's part of the process yeah I have
never met anyone that achieved a high
level of like physicality whether
skateboarding boxing whatever that
didn't break like 10 things and I'm like
that's just part of it you just have to
go through that yeah and uh so like
being able to read biographies and see
how like people actually did it
helped me reduce some of the fear that
was taught to me that people just
avoided you know no you don't do this
because this happens you don't do that
because that happens yeah yeah yeah so
yeah I did I just didn't I didn't get
exposed to it like that so I didn't
really
even care to know that it existed oh I
think I probably related it too much to
school and I'm like I don't want it I
see
um so that and then
um
uh someone that
just likes to [ __ ] plow through [ __ ]
like I just felt like growing up
everyone was just again maybe it's the
fear thing but I felt like everyone just
moved so slow or just waited on other
people you know like or just too many
assumptions were being made like I just
felt like people would just move or make
decisions so slowly you know or they
would wait for like this chain of
command to finally let them go like huh
you can move yeah yeah and for me I was
always like why why like let me just
[ __ ] go but they're Bound by spider
webs yeah you know and one of the most
um one of the the memories that my mom
always brings up about me where she was
like man this [ __ ] is built different
and it's something so small but now
looking back at it I know where it came
from
um but I think uh and again it's a
really small example but my mom was mind
blown this is to goes to show you what I
was kind of dealing with
um in terms of like the fear or just
people moving so [ __ ] slow so I
remember you know where my brother lives
now that's the house I mainly grew up in
yeah so the front door that we walk in
and out of there was this [ __ ]
weather strip on the bottom of it that
was just sticking out for [ __ ] ever
and it would just bother the [ __ ] out of
me because one it looks sloppy there was
a draft you couldn't close it properly
and it seemed like such a simple thing
to do
everyone walks in and out of this door
every [ __ ] day I'm probably like
a fourth grader maybe fifth grader I was
really young yeah yeah
um that door is solidwood solid wood I
didn't know that okay so everyone was
walking through this door [ __ ] every
day
they're allowing that to happen and I'm
like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] like there's
nobody give a [ __ ] this is [ __ ] crazy
to me like I just couldn't believe that
something's so small
was let go for so long and this is it's
it's tiny it should be tiny yeah and I'm
like I've had [ __ ] enough this is
enough this is [ __ ] Insanity so I I'm
trying to fix it I can't do it
um I'm just trying to slide it back in
trying to like correct it or whatever
can't do it I feel no one else is home I
don't know where everyone is is for
whatever reason I'm like I've had enough
this is it so I take the [ __ ] door
off the hinges oh [ __ ] yeah and I'm like
I'm gonna [ __ ] fix this [ __ ] this is
so stupid so I take it off wow I can't
[ __ ] hold the door because it's
[ __ ] heaviest it's solid
[ __ ] wood yeah I thought it was
those cool those cool ones that are
super Hollow where it's just like
particle board on each side yeah and I'm
like oh [ __ ] man I'm gonna get in
trouble what the [ __ ] but I'm like [ __ ]
it I need a muscle this [ __ ] I'm trying
to fix it and stuff
um and I do I I end up doing it but it's
all crooked so my dad and my mom come
home they're like what the [ __ ] happened
to the store and I was like oh yeah and
and I was like I just couldn't take it
like I just needed did you fix it it's
fixed yeah and instead and I was like
book I'm gonna get in trouble like what
did I do I'm [ __ ] everything up
because like for me that's big people's
[ __ ] you know and I could have ruined it
and it costs money and like I just
didn't really know the mechanics of how
it worked so I'm like oh my God I'm
gonna [ __ ] they're gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of me
um but they were so amused and they were
so impressed that I did that that they
were just laughing they're like you're
[ __ ] crazy I can't believe you're
kidding me you did that all by yourself
like it was more of like a proud moment
for me because I I was just like oh [ __ ]
I think I did something good but I
didn't really understand what I did
because I just always felt that so I'm
like I don't understand why you guys
didn't do that that's one of uh your one
of my favorite qualities of you what
there you're just down to just move
forward because like
um the way that I I saw myself as a kid
I always wanted to be some sort of like
Warrior dude and then I also knew I
needed Like a Warrior Queen with me
and so like that's always so easy for me
to just get out of relationships because
as soon as it didn't feel like the
trajectory matched where I wanted to go
or what I envisioned as a kid I'm like
oh it's not gonna work but because I
always imagine I don't know why but I
always had this fantasy of like we're
going somewhere and the dad takes an
arrow
oh my God
and then I look at the mom
you know and my mom's like see you later
[ __ ] so you need the amount to be
strong and like plow like physically and
mentally and spiritually and so um I
always felt that about you and I was
like she can bear my seed
so yeah like
got it
um I'm like oh that's pretty tight you
know because I think I always felt like
there was just people were just kind of
moving through Jello and I'm like why it
doesn't have to be this [ __ ] slow
just one foot in front of the other we
don't have to know what the [ __ ] we're
doing but we just gotta [ __ ] move and
that like always drove me crazy about
the people around me yeah that I'm like
okay you guys are talking about it but
where's the [ __ ] movement like let's
just do something let's do anything
opposite of what we're doing now and
that's good
um so that's another quality that like
if little me had big sister me that it'd
be like oh man she would have flourished
um another one is is kind of what along
the lines of what you're talking about
right like the ethics and The Virtue and
stuff and there's been so many and just
the the the the courage there's been so
many times where I've fought my brain to
be like don't say it don't say it stay
out of it don't do it don't do it and
I'm like oh but I have to like something
else inside of me is always like you
have to speak up or you have to take
action or you have to not in a um any
time that I felt like I needed to stand
up
and when I didn't afterwards I always
felt so bad yes and I always have to
tell myself don't you dare ever let that
happen again yeah same same there's
there's only a handful of moments where
I'm like [ __ ] that I regret that I
didn't open my mouth or did I have way
more regrets of me opening my mouth but
I'm like I think the ones that weigh
more are the ones where I'm like [ __ ] I
knew I should have said something and I
didn't or I knew I should have taken
action and I didn't
um and I felt like that's really
contributed to a lot of the confidence
and courage that I have today uh there
were so many times where either my
friend's Circle or my family or just
people around me where I'm like there's
a [ __ ] elephant in the room and we
need to [ __ ] address it nobody's
talking about it what the [ __ ] is going
on and then I'm I'm the one that puts it
out there first like if if little Geo
would have seen that I would have been
like oh she's awesome I want to be like
that you know because I know that
everyone's thinking it everyone's
feeling it but no one's doing anything
about it like just say something and
I've always like
like I feel like we've all see and feel
the exact same thing and I've had the
knots in my throat where I'm like [ __ ] I
don't want to do this but like I do it
you know do you ever feel that way
um about social media
about talking about it yeah because you
know the elephant in the room there's
that in the room I was afraid it was the
elephant in the world yeah and then
sometimes it feels like no one in the
world is talking about things yeah but
we all know we are thinking about it and
feeling about it
um do you ever want to feel like you
want to be that on social media so yes
and no yes because I feel like we should
all be talking about things that are
hard to talk about yeah right so yes so
that's why I'm always applauding and and
um
and
um supporting those that do because I
know it's hard yeah but then no because
I don't like I don't like attention
ironically enough and I don't want even
if it's good attention like I don't care
what the attention is I just don't want
it at all so that's why when like big
life moments happen for me or like like
if it's if it's like a big
congratulations or like taika's born or
like you know my father passed like if
there's a lot of attention it just it
gives me way too much anxiety and I just
don't know how to compute it it's just
way too much emotion for me where I'm
like I don't want like I just want to be
in a cave like good or bad so because of
that I I I would prefer it when it's
mourn in an intimate setting if it's
like a one-on-one thing or just like a
handful of people I see because you know
once it's too much attention's happening
and I'm like leading this thing or like
all eyes are on me I'm like
but I don't want it yeah yeah so because
that's why it's a yes and no for me I
see yeah I don't know where that comes
from or why but I just
I just don't like it yeah sometimes I
wish I could be brave enough to step out
onto social media
and like try to like lead or try to like
like be a thought leader
um but I also know like
sometimes people aren't ready for it and
it takes context you know like there
could be something that like
you know how like um
in algebra or like in basic math you say
like you can't divide by negative
numbers remember that like that rule you
can't divide by negative numbers and
then in algebra two you realize all
about it you realize you can't yeah like
or like even square root of like
negative one is I now you know so like
once you get to a certain level you
realize that was only contained so it's
easy to understand but once you get to a
certain level everything is way more
yeah and I think the problem with social
media for me and why I can't do it is I
feel like the ocean is too big
so when you're going like you know what
this is what we need to do for this
ocean then there's people in the
Atlantic Ocean no that doesn't happen
over here or someone in this sea that
doesn't happen over here but then I'm
like but you guys haven't seen the
greater ocean yeah you know or maybe I
might even be speaking from a place of
not that great of an ocean but um
but I feel like I would still like to
put it out there so that we can
challenge each other's thoughts but I
also feel like in social media at least
this climate it's not as like
2012 or 2015 where people are are in a
good exchange of thoughts like like
exchanging thoughts I don't think it's
ever been like that quickly become
uh heated emotions yeah and I'm like
that's not productive yeah yeah I don't
think it's ever been like that yeah and
I don't think it ever can be like that
because there's just too many you know
it's like a big sea of things but
um so yeah that was a that's a quality
in myself now that I'm really happy that
I kept pushing forward
um because growing up I didn't see that
like I saw
I felt like people knew more than they
and I enjoy that too but I felt like
people knew more than what they
um shared and then because of that which
I saw it as something very Noble to be
humble that way
and to to not make people feel bad or or
you know to allow people the floor to
speak on things but at the same time
presented in the wrong hands it would
really belittle that person
so then I think I I gravitated towards
both of those things of going like wow
that's so humble and I really do love
that and then the other side of going
like but yeah sometimes you got to speak
the [ __ ] up and and not necessarily put
people in their place but just let your
position be known yeah do you um ever go
like
like you wanted to be you're you're
striving to be the woman role model you
wish you had right
I don't know if I would present it that
way
um well maybe now I'm saying I feel
guilty saying yes to that question
because I see how strong my mom really
was now but growing up I didn't
understand it so you're like so I don't
have had a strong woman I just didn't
recognize it yeah yeah and and because
she's not me and I'm not her
um we're two different people I can
appreciate her now and see her strength
but that's not necessarily how I would
have done things I see so like I can
respect that now whereas back then it
was actually a driver a driving force
for me to be more of myself and not that
yeah that's also one thing I realized
too where I think when you're younger
you're painting in Broad Strokes yeah
and then as you get older there's more
and more Nuance yeah so as a kid that's
why I couldn't even fathom like what do
you mean someone that's like kind of
like badass but is also silly man yeah
whereas like now I realized some of the
most baddest dudes are like Tim Kenny is
[ __ ] silly as [ __ ] yeah he's the best
like there's like so many silly people
and there's like so many nuances you
know you could have a guy that is like
Suave and smooth but also very Macho or
you could have a you know there's like
so many people or so many different yeah
they're multifaceted so many colors of
paint there's not just this anymore yeah
so that's why now I would rate myself
higher than I did as a as a kid yeah
yeah oh that's CUNY yeah and that's one
thing that I think uh really keeps me
grounded and keeps me from ever going in
a dark place just because I'm just so
proud of the work I've done with myself
do you think you would Express
the role model selves the role model
self of you differently
if you had a son or a daughter
say that again I think that's too stupid
yeah you are do what you would you
express a different role model self so
for example right for me when I was a
kid I'm a boy so I'm looking for boy
Role Models AKA men I'm like okay that's
the man I want to be right because I'm
thinking what does my son need I see and
then I have a daughter and I'm like oh
[ __ ] that's different no what does my
daughter need my daughter's not gonna
need the same thing that I was trying to
be you know what I mean so like for you
um
do you think if you had if you had a
daughter
you would be like oh I need to express
other sides of this role model self that
I'm trying to become for my daughter
for me
um my virtues or what I considered my
virtues and just my own version of
ethics and my own values were so clear
for me that they didn't have a gender
like everyone should be possessing this
thing like everyone should have like
honesty is in a female
or male trait you know what about
picking what to eat shut the [ __ ] up
which one's that is that more male or
more female that's just someone that has
a very
Advanced palette and they have just so
many things to choose from no but
um yeah it wouldn't matter because all
of the things that I that I strived for
weren't a thing that needed to be
attached to a gender right speaking up
being brave moving forward moving
um like trying to achieve hard things
like that's not gender specific how does
that help you make a sandwich though
I don't make sandwiches oh you don't I
[ __ ] eat them and my husband makes my
goddamn sandwiches I don't know how you
like them too yeah thank you yeah cut
off the crust and make it toasty I'm
just kidding but yeah it wouldn't make a
difference
um and I feel like once it does make a
difference then I'm not then I'm doing
everyone a disservice
right because why should anything be
tied to a gender like there's roles
there could be roles and there could be
gender roles if you'd like but even
Within These gender roles
um it doesn't necessarily mean that it
has to be like a woman doing woman thing
and a man doing man things like I think
you know we all come from like a
spectrum of like masculine and feminine
traits like you might like in our
relationship you might be the tender one
you know and that's that was perceived
to be a female thing but I don't think
there's anything wrong with you being
tender and me not being as tender right
like biologically I guess we're wired
that way but if we somehow like if our
biologies were like just slightly
different because no one is the exact
same but if somehow like if we met and
now we balance each other sick that's
tight yeah I don't I don't think any of
that should be tied to male or female
because I think
um
I would be a little bit different
what yeah do you think it's because
you're a man it could be so you know how
like every time I leave yeah I what do I
always tell taika he's got to take care
of Mama yeah you always gotta take care
of mama you know and then
he was like it's ready you know he could
do it but then what would you tell a
girl I don't think I would tell that's I
was thinking I don't think I would tell
that to a girl why not I don't know I
don't think I would tell her to because
now that taking care could also be
different
it could be but I think like because I
relate so much to that yeah it's natural
whereas where I think if it was a girl
it might be a second language and yeah
you're right it could be that in her own
way but I don't speak that language yet
yeah so I think with like taika like the
man I want him to become it's easy
because I am a man and I am becoming a
man I want to become so I think it's
like it's like teaching a right-hander a
right hand something yes the left hand
is supposed to do exactly what the right
hand does wow but now you're a
right-hander teaching left hand is how I
feel it it's nuts because if I had a
daughter I would still say the same
thing
right and now it's now I understand
though that it's gonna be
um left to their own perception of what
that means yeah yeah yeah right because
you're telling Tyco protect your mom
which now you're going I'm gonna be
Night Watch right what's that sound but
taika is perceiving it as like oh I'm
gonna get my mom a blanket oh um my mom
coughed oh let me Pat her on the back
that's taken care of her yeah anyway
anyway in his little mind that he's
taking care of his mom interesting is
put your mama first when Papa's not
running I'll take care of her mama I'm
trying to think and it's maybe I don't
remember or maybe just it never happened
but I'm trying to think if I was ever
put in a box like a lady supposed to do
this but you also value gender roles too
um there is some sort of loose box yeah
maybe yeah because I value gender roles
yeah no I do if I hear that like someone
shatter the front door I'm not gonna buy
babe
get the gun I'll meet you outside yeah
yeah I do appreciate it I'll get the gun
I'll meet you outside yeah I mean that's
what I saw you know yeah and it worked
for me so I'm I don't know if this is my
Libra side not to get all foofy but I've
always always always
um uh appreciate balance balance in all
aspects of Life literally all aspects of
life balance balance doesn't always mean
symmetry
it doesn't yeah so I think what are you
saying balance meaning like it just you
have to have the opposite of the other
yeah that to me is also that's the way
the same but it doesn't have to be
symmetry it doesn't have to be
symmetrical yeah
right I'm that I think so what I'm
saying is I know what no I know what
you're saying but I think I challenge
you what I'm saying and I'm going to
challenge thank you because I always I'm
also challenging me is what I said okay
good we're both challenging yeah because
I think it's because symmetry means I
have a five pound weight here here's
also five pounds no no yes but balance
is here's a five pound weight here's
five one pound weights but we're holding
the same weight
yeah so it doesn't have to look the same
right so for example I think one of the
beautiful relationships that we have is
um
because cooking is more natural to me
the minute it's dinner time it's you
help typo with that's balance right so
it's not where it's not symmetrical
right right right right but we're
holding the same weight we're both
taking care of the family that's what
I'm saying in that hour or two hours or
whatever yeah yeah yeah
um but so it's not symmetrical but it's
the same but it's balanced yeah because
I see it as okay you're taking care of
them this way I'm taking care of them
this way we're both taken care of yeah
so for me everything has to have balance
even when it's something really good
that's happening I have to have the
balance of going not anticipating the
bad but also being aware that the bad
exists or the bad just happened or like
um I don't know I don't really like to
focus on the bad too much but just going
like [ __ ] I just left the bad thing and
now I'm experiencing the good yeah you
know never forgetting that that's there
like I just I I have to have to help for
the best but be prepared for the worst
right and then so having this balance
also translates to things being fair all
the time and I always feel like things
need to to be fair when they're not fair
I have to fix that
yeah and you know this like you know
even in our relationship something as
small as like okay you paid this time I
have to pay the next time and you're
like no I want to take care of you and
I'm like but that's not fair I've been
taking care of years
thank you so High
um but yeah stuff like that and I'm I'm
really proud of the journey I've had and
I'm really proud of you know the
mistakes I've made and like you know me
being able to get up and like do that
and get up and like learn from it and
and become better
um and I don't normally like talking
about myself this way because I do
um I feel like I don't know [ __ ] and I
feel like I'm not [ __ ]
but I also have to be real with myself
and appreciate myself and be like yeah
but you're here you know and you've done
some cool [ __ ] and then you're going oh
yeah that's true but I don't really like
dwelling on it yeah 39 year old backpack
that's empty that's [ __ ] weird you
better have a lot of stuff in there yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but I'm really
happy that I've stuck out a lot of
things like I've I've been through some
hard [ __ ] and I've been able to like
I've learned about some really hard [ __ ]
and some hard truths and I've
experienced a bunch of hard [ __ ] and
just going like damn that's tight like
I've seen the silver lining in every
every aspect of that and I've you know
and and there are some things you know
that I'm not really proud of but then
still going like damn but that's not
you know that like you know I am
disappointed in myself or whatever but
then going like but I'm not defined by
that
and like like actually believing it and
going like it is what it is learn from
it move keep it Trucking yep yeah I do
want to be the weather Jeep wrinkle the
weather Jeep the weathered Jeep just
because you've experienced so much at
the end of my life yeah and you're still
Chugga lugging yeah I think at the end
of my life I want to be the weather Jeep
on
on the front lawn than to be like the
polished Rolls Royce in the garage I
want to have the dings and the dents uh
maybe the mismatched tires
um maybe a couple of tickets that still
needs to be paid off don't say like this
is specific
it was like a Disney movie it's all cute
is it it's all sad it feels like an up
type of movie that you're describing to
me right now yeah it's really CUNY well
I don't know I just want to be like a
Jeep with dings and stickers and stuff
and stuff like that I don't want to
think about you old that's what I want
to be so I want to keep doing hard [ __ ]
you know and keep becoming the person
that
um
I think I would have liked to look up to
I would like Taiko to look up to thank
you and then even also when taika has
kids he's like Grandpa was [ __ ] cool
you know you need to like you need to
talk to grandpa he has cool stories and
yeah Grandpa made me who I am today why
are you making me cry you [ __ ]
that's so cute that's what I want to be
versus the the [ __ ] squeaky clean
Grandpa like the Japanese car zero
stories yeah and they're like What's
grandpa oh he just [ __ ] he just crosses
his legs and dabs his mouth if you don't
know the Japanese car
um look up how pristine Japanese people
keep their cars like they could be
driving a [ __ ] 86 Corolla and the
paint job is immaculate yeah they're
culture their cultures they wipe their
car down every day damn it's there's
like not a [ __ ] dust flake on their
cars and everything that's supposed to
be white is [ __ ] white everything
that's supposed to be Chrome is so
polished yeah they really take care of
their [ __ ] out there yeah and you don't
want to be that guy yeah I want to be
dings scratches I want to have all the
scarves yeah when I grow old
I just want to be the wise [ __ ] old
lady that all the youngsters
want to take advice from
because I'm like I've seen some [ __ ] and
I'm not gonna judge you I'm gonna listen
I'm gonna try to help you yeah
that was CUNY I don't know why I'm all
choked up I just I feel like taika
remember when he was like Mom he's like
I don't want you to become a grandma I
think it's for him once people become
grandmas he knows what's right around
the corner and they're gonna die
so he was crying saying Mom I don't want
you to be a grandma and I'm like
I won't I won't do it dude I don't know
what else to say but I'm like I'm not
gonna do it I swear I'm not gonna be a
grandma and he just stopped crying he's
like okay yeah like [ __ ] who's gonna
tell him he's very cute how sweet he is
yeah he's the best but yeah I think that
just the idea of you being old and [ __ ]
oh I could cry anyway on that note I
better wrap it up before I [ __ ] lose
my [ __ ] thank you guys so much for
listening and like what BART said in the
beginning of this of this video make
sure to like it thumbs it up let us know
how you feel about it throw us some
comments
um share some of your stories tell us if
you're proud of yourself that's so dope
to just put it out into the world and
like get it out of your brain put it on
paper or on the screen and like read how
proud of yourself you are and if you're
not take this as an opportunity to
really switch that [ __ ] up it's never
too late to be proud of yourself you can
be like [ __ ] on your deathbed and if
that one thing that held you back was
like apologizing or saying this thing or
admitting this other thing I mean damn
you can go with like still being proud
that you like had the courage to [ __ ]
stand up to yourself anyway on that note
thank you so much and we'll see you next
week adios